[Music]
what if South was north and North was
South just like 780 thousand years ago
the world didn't come to an end then but
how would it react now that we rely so
heavily on technology with this
electromagnetic disruption kill us all
with solar radiation make the planet
uninhabitable this is what if and here's
what would happen if Earth's magnetic
poles flipped overnight wait didn't we
say it already happened before Earth's
magnetic field has been around for at
least 4.2 billion years it acts as a
giant shield to protect our planet from
being burned by cosmic radiation the
fields north and south poles used to
switch places every 200,000 to 300,000
years but the current poles have been
holding steady for the past 780
millennia if the poles suddenly reversed
should we be ready for a geomagnetic
apocalypse spoiler alert humanity
wouldn't die out but the world as we
know it would flipping the poles
wouldn't make the geomagnetic field
disappear but it would strip away at
least ten percent of its current force
everything on earth would be exposed to
higher levels of radiation but wouldn't
we still have the atmosphere to protect
us what we would but with a weak
magnetic field flaming hot particles
from the Sun would slam into our ozone
layer and puncture it extra ultraviolet
radiation would damage human tissue and
cause mutations skin cancer could become
as common as the flu would our
technology be in danger
absolutely solar particles would rip
through sensitive electronics over
orbital satellites damaging them heavily
for the US economy alone a single big
solar storm would cost as much as forty
two billion dollars per day eventually
all communication systems would fail as
with the electrical grids that rely on
satellite timing systems these grids are
all tightly connected to each other if
even one of them was critically damaged
the others would fail too this would
cause a domino run of blackouts around
the world blackouts that could last for
decades
rapid magnetic pole reversal would throw
us back three centuries in terms of
electronics you wouldn't be able to
charge your phone or use your computer
even your flush toilet would be useless
it would quickly get backed up since
most sewer systems rely on electricity
to move waste on top of that high UV
exposure could make some parts of the
planet uninhabitable and what about
animals with the polar flip affect them
at all some of them for sure along with
many other species migratory birds
turtles whales bees and salmon use
magnetic ssin to navigate if North
turned to South they'd be quite confused
however since many of these species were
around for the last pole flip it's
possible they'd figure it out the truth
is the power of our geomagnetic field
has been getting weaker for the last
hundred and sixty years are we moving
towards a reversal scientists believe we
could be less than a thousand years away
from one the poles wouldn't flip over
night but as they move Earth's magnetic
field could be compromised for centuries
the cool thing about it all you'd be
able to see incredible Aurora's at much
lower latitudes you might choose to go
to Tahiti rather than Iceland to see
these epic nighttime skies
[Music]